[Applause]
[Music]
have you ever heard this phrase sounds
pretty good right I mean it's quite a
proclamation a call to an epic objective
an appeal to the people's pride towards
resistance the truth is though that over
the years this slogan has become one of
the chants the essential slogans of
every protest especially in Latin
America and especially in protests and
demonstrations of Marxist Leninist
Maoist and socialist movements of all
kinds well when I want to think now way
below me the paradigm in the field of it
all
look at that all regarding saddled
because throughout the 20th century
these types of chants proclamations and
slogans supported a huge number of
groups and protest movements throughout
Latin America this happened to such an
extent that in many cases these epic ins
brave slogans they had a far more
terrible phenomenon a phenomenon that
became one of the most remarkable
characteristics of the entire region
the guerrillas
now what does the guerrilla phenomenon
consist of and why did it emerge I mean
how could gorillas have such an impact
and so much power and what's their
situation like today well we're gonna
answer all of those questions in this
video but first a bit of history and why
we the spark that ignited the flame
is the 1960s the guerrilla phenomenon is
about to begin the Cuban Revolution
it's just happens and folks we really
can't talk about gorillas in Latin
America without taking Cuba's role into
accounts yep you are that right the
Cuban Revolution was a great source of
inspiration for all kinds of anti
imperialist revolutionary and communist
movements not only that but over the
years Cuba also became the number-one
promoter of guerrilla groups in the
entire region yeah we could say that
Cuba it was quite a powerful stage in
that sense but the fact is that the myth
of the Cuban Revolution was the main
reason that thousands of young idealists
in many cases with good intentions helps
turn Latin America into a hornet's nest
how could they resist the exploits of
the great commander Fidel Castro the
leader that supposedly managed to get
the revolution running with just 82
people if he could do it
why couldn't others I mean get the rifle
boys let's crack on well many of these
young people they clearly felt this
quite servant Lee
[Music]
you see the truth is that the revolution
managed to triumph to a great extent
precisely because of the excessive
violence and repression of the Cuban
dictator Fulgencio Batista these were
excesses that got a good part of the
army including several officers who
aligned with Castro's groups and by the
way did you know that unlike what's
commonly said this heroic revolution it
didn't really have a clear idea logical
objective
[Music]
at first in 1959 Fidel Castro he never
tired of repeating again and again to
the Cuban people among others that he
wasn't a communist Fidel himself he said
this I know you're worried about whether
or not we're communists I want to make
this clear
we aren't communists I'm not a communist
and neither is our movement Fidel Castro
communist and in a future video we
probably do need to talk about the Cuban
Revolution so we'll do that at some
point in the future but folks many many
members over the revolution they were
communists however it wasn't until two
years after the revolutionary triumphs
in 1961 that Fidel declared himself a
Marxist Leninist and proclaimed the
socialist revolution and ethics we can
ask ourselves two questions what changed
in these two years and why is this
important well listen up
[Music]
operation center
let's speak there Washington politicians
never believed Fidel Castro statements
denying communism in fact they saw this
new regime in Havana as their danger
during the Cold War that's how the
disastrous Bay of Pigs invasion attempt
emerged at the same time this was quite
clear to the soviet union leaders cuba
meant an incredible opportunity and
mainly for three reasons first by
aligned with cuba they'd gained a very
advantageous geographical position to
the United States they would have a
friendly territory and a military base
just a few kilometers from the American
mainland second a socialist Cuba would
mean a new satellite state thus
reinforcing their position in
international politics and third Cuba
could become the operation center to
spread communism in the US as so called
backyard that's Latin America
that way folks that Soviet Union's
chances of winning the Cold War
they absolutely grew stronger and you
know what as we usually say here at
visual politics that was said and so it
was done the regime then led by Nikita
Khrushchev concentrated on consolidating
its relations with the new Castro aiight
Cuba and it was quite a strong focus
from that very moment Cuba became a
center for training financing and
supplying equipment and weapons for
their revolutionary movements throughout
the continent
that's how Havana became the biggest
guerrilla uprising promoter in latin
america the duty of every revolutionary
is to make the revolution the second
declaration of Havana February 4th 1962
the idea development by Al Shea was that
a small group of activists could
initiate typical guerrilla war actions
and blow up existing institutions to
spread the flames of the socialist
revolution and not just that they also
promoted a new strategy known as
cultural Marxism this by the way it's
still seen in many places so what
exactly does this strategy consist of
basically it's using education and
culture to help communists and
revolutionary ideologies infiltrate
society to this end the Cuban regime
supported the creation of songs poems
university writings and literary works
of all kinds with a common
characteristic all of them were steeped
in revolutionary ideology and among
other things extolled the guerrilla
figure take education and culture and
the rest will a Don Antonio Gramsci now
do you want to know more about how
Havana supported some of the most famous
guerrillas well listen up
[Music]
ize the first operation
it happens in Nicaragua thanks to Moscow
and Savannah's technical military and
economic support the revolutionary
leader Carlos Fonseca Amador promoted
the creation and organization of the
sandanista National Liberation Front in
1961 if you've heard of it that's
probably because it's Daniel Ortega's
movements who's the current tyrant
president of Nicaragua about which we've
already spoken in several videos
AirVenture politic but let's go back to
it in 1969
Carlos Fonseca moved to Havana where he
spent the next six years from there he
organized the sandanista front in 1975
he returns to Nicaragua to solve some
leadership problems and unify the
guerrilla group and although a year
later this revolutionary leader was
assassinated in 1979 the Sandinista
fronts they finally seized power the
guerrilla trained and financed and
supported by Havana had triumphed the
model it worked so why stop in 1980 a
year after the Sandinista fronts triumph
the FML the fair Abunda Marti fronts for
national liberation was founded in El
Salvador with Fidel Castro himself as an
intermediary and what's more this group
it was founded in Havana itself
[Music]
well with the support of the Cuban
regime along with that of the new
Nicaraguan government and Moscow of
course the FML started its armed fight
their training centers were located in
Cuba and Nicaragua and of course it was
those same countries which provided them
with weapons supplies equipment and
anything else they need it now hold on
for a moment but as you can imagine the
United States didn't just stand there
they weren't willing to give Havana
another victory so they decided to
support the Salvadoran government the
result 12 years of fighting that caused
more than 75,000 deaths
thousands more missing and an economic
collapse
[Music]
I think that now we can begin to
understand the magnitude of the violence
that has destroyed so much of this
region the fact is that on this occasion
the guerrillas they didn't achieve a
revolution and after the peace
agreements of 1990 they formed a
political party today this party governs
El Salvador and of course it hasn't
hesitated to support Daniel Ortega's
Nicaraguan regime but don't think for a
second that this situation has happened
solely in Central America not at all the
southern countries they also had their
share South America also underwent a
wave of revolutionary movements in fact
throughout Latin America more than a
hundred hundred guerrilla groups caused
enormous damage almost all of them were
encouraged and supported by Cuba in one
way or another that's certainly true for
the most famous guerrilla groups FARC
the April 19th movement in Colombia and
the Shining Path in Peru The Shining
Path activists have been trained in Cuba
Czechoslovakia and the German Democratic
Republic Manuel hulloa former prime
minister of Peru and statements to the
El Pais newspaper in 1983
are you surprised now that the peace
agreements between FARC and Juan Manuel
Santos as Colombian government will be
negotiated in Havana
of course these huge groups true armies
also had another fundamental support
point this drug money yep these groups
ended up becoming drug traffickers a
business from which they obtains the
enormous resources they needed to
continue the fight
but also don't forget that Cuba also
went into this business we told you
about that here on visual politic in a
recent video about narco politics in
this region of the world yes the Cuban
government even associated with Pablo
Escobar himself and that's not all
the last example of Cuban infiltration
we all know was in Venezuela and we've
already seen how things are going there
[Music]
folks Cuba's influence on Latin American
politics in the last 60 years has been
terrible Havana has played a major role
in back in guerrilla groups and regimes
that have done absolutely no good for
Latin America yeah and I know nowadays
some people still view these groups with
a certain romanticism but that really is
a mistake
beyond the feats and the myths the real
story unfortunately it's terrible but
fortunately the guerrillas are now at
their lowest point in decades and that
at least is good news by the way many of
the guerrilla groups they weren't just
have honest faults in too many cases
they were the fault of a terribly
extractive oligarchy that controlled
their country with an interest in
nothing but maintaining their own
privileges this has also been one of the
great evils of the region so with this
video we hopefully now better understand
how so many guerrilla groups suddenly
emerged in Latin America and why
relations between Washington and Havana
have traditionally been so bad the story
it goes far beyond the Missile Crisis so
I really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did please don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos also don't forget
to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine also this channel it's possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please do consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you next time
[Music]